irving now on the corner is guarded by
osman
irving spins fires from the baseline at
kansas
kyrie irving gets the nets on the board
irving now on the corner is guarded by
osman irving spins fires from the
baseline and kansas
kyrie irving gets the nets on the board
in the most recent draft now guards
kyrie irving
irving straight away from three
what does damien dotson will check into
the next dead ball as hard
with a clean steal back in the nets
three on two irving hesitates around
sexton glides to the hole and the nets
lead by eight
allen is long and quick so you got to be
real cognizant of where he is
and that's what helped him uh defend
that shot
durant puts it up and in gets fouled by
prince and kevin durant
has a chance for the three-point play
and then in transition
they are awful tough in transition
one-on-one shuffling exercise for jb
bickerstabs that
shot by hardin is short cracked down by
brown the nets
reset durant's open he'll fire and he'll
score
i think he can last hit two or three
seasons
kyrie irving back in the ball game
zigzags into an 18-footer we mentioned
kyrie had played only one game
previously
in this building since his departure
from the cavs going on the floor is that
colin stepped on the sideline
as he was coming up the floor after the
block on the kevin durant shot as
meanwhile here's irving
a 15-footer is good as kyrie is five of
seven from the field
he has a team high 11 points and stay in
bounds indeed he does try to find a
cutter in nan's play getting scrambly
here
on the offensive end for the cavaliers
is durant now toward dotson
finger rolls and cuts the cavs lead to
two pretty lengthy lineup here
for the cavaliers irving goes to work
off a jordan screen does not need
much room kyrie has 13. prince's first
bucket as a member of the cavaliers
irving at the foul line twists fires and
scores the cavs have to understand
make this work for this team everybody
is not going to be able to score 30 at
night
dotson with a gorgeous move he got
hardened leaning the wrong way irving to
the bucket
durant had 11 first half points finds
harden
harden step back three that's his first
field goal
half number one that's exactly what he's
doing and what he did
drummond checked in tied for fifth in
the entire nba in deflections hardened
around
datsun his teardrop doesn't go but as
follow does as
hardin guides it in with the left hand
and trims the cavs lead to four
osmond now has a game high 21 he's seven
of 11 from the field
irving dribbling baseline scores he got
around drummond was able to elude nance
at the rim
durant pops it to himself he's out here
with perry harden luabu cabaret and
harris
durant to the bucket
durant spins fires long luau cabaret
with that long reach keeps the
possession alive goes back to harris
they'll swoop one off to hardin for a
three
durant with a rebound with a shot clock
off yeah i didn't think that
his his throw moved like that for
nothing
durant sneaks around nan's baseline
ads have to be very diligent in how they
execute in this quarter
kyrie irving's back on the floor he has
a team high 20 points he goes to work
cavaliers have taken a 13-point lead and
not giving up on the play
duran draws the foul has a chance for
four
now that's called second and third
effort and with the momentum building up
knocking that jumper down durant from
three he has an answer
oh my god
now that's called second and third
effort and with the momentum building up
knocking that jumper down durant from
three he has an answer
oh my hardin watched by the rookie okoro
the shot clock shows five carded now
picked up by
sexton launches a long distance three
can't do shots like that against this
team they make you pay durant off the
hardened feed
works into a 12-footer and cuts the cavs
lead to three he works it off to green
now hardin hardin toward osmond feeds a
wide open irving
[Applause]
kyrie irving has 28 in the cavalier lead
is two second chance opportunities
they're just too good
cavaliers still up 3 37 to go on the
fourth
hardened stop and go harden
count it off the window a little dipsy
do from the old school move of james
harden
and this is the craftiness of james
hartson look he's got one on his back
waits for jared allen
ten points eight rebounds for allen and
his cavalier debut
durant winds into a mid-range jumper
durant now has
30. the shot clock shows six
harden bounces to harris harris off the
sideline to the bucket lays it up missed
the shot
put back is good irving got his hands on
it he's tied this game at 113.
nance defends durant
irving off a screen sexton got hung up
and irving doesn't hesitate
he has 33 and he's given the nets a 116
113 ed agoro
carter by irving zips one into allen in
the paint allen spin puts it up blocked
by duran sexton got it back
that's blocked by irving
again not quite able to get the ball up
to the basket good defense
durant's playing center guard forward
harden now on the run to the bucket back
toward durant
durant accelerates floats scores gets
fouled and kevin durant
has a chance for three in this overtime
gets inside so smooth
they're doing too much dribbling
individually they gotta
trust who they are and not get caught up
in one-on-one play
hardin finds durant what a catch and
what a finish he's giving the nets a 120
115 lead
it's a seven point game once again
sexton is wearing him out tonight
irving stops on a dime he connects kyrie
has
35. this is what kevin durant james
harden and kyrie irving are accustomed
to doing
two other teams throughout their careers
irving at the bucket
with the finit what a game tonight here
from downtown cleveland
hardin goes baseline and scores harden
has 21 points